Speaker 1: Well, folks,
another tragic accident where
an individual who just happened to be critical of
Russian President Vladimir Putin has very sadly
and very accidentally fallen to
his death out of a hotel window.
It's almost like this is an epidemic in Russia.
By mere coincidence, people who criticize Vladimir
Putin fall out of windows, sometimes in an act of
taking their own life, as it is reported. So here
is what we have. And yes, it is another one of
these stories. It's really December 27th, 2022
today. This isn't a repeat of the story like this
from two months ago or six months ago or whatever.
Russian meat magnate. This is the sausage king
of Russia. Apparently, I'm not even exaggerating
that Russian meat magnate who criticized Putin's
war dies after a hotel fall of Russian sausage
magnate who briefly criticized Russia's invasion
of Ukraine has died after falling from the third
floor window of a luxury hotel in India. Pavel
Antonov was a member of Putin's United Russia
Party and a multimillionaire, having founded one
of the country's largest sausage makers. He was
reportedly on a trip to celebrate his upcoming
66th birthday when he was found lying in a pool
of blood outside the Hotel CI International
and ran Riot Garda in the southern state of
Odisha. An unnamed police official told India's
NDTV news outlet. They suspect he took his own
life because he was depressed about the death of
his friend who was found dead at the same hotel.
Hmm. Vladimir Bid Deneuve was found
unconscious in his hotel room on Thursday,
surrounded by empty wine bottles. And Top
was the founder of the Vladimir Standard.
A major meat producer had an income
of just under $230 million a year.
In July, he posted a story on his WhatsApp
criticizing Russia's missile attacks on Kiev
as terrorism. He was referring to reports of a
girl that was pulled from rubble after a house
was shelled shortly afterward. He apologized
for the post and said it was posted by someone
else. Someone got into his WhatsApp and sent
a message. He said he was a supporter of the
president and my country's patriot and shared
the goals of the invention and the invasion.
The Russia consul general in Calcutta
said there was no foul play. So listen,
was there fell foul play or not? I don't know.
But it's very strange. I mean, even that story.
He was at the same hotel where another
Russian died. And he was so depressed by that
that he took his own life. It's very strange.
And of course this endlessly expanded wiki
article 2022 Russian Businessmen Mystery
Deaths. You might remember in January we
covered the death of Leonard Shulman. We later
covered. There's so many of these. I don't
remember all of the ones that we covered more.
I believe we covered the Pavel the of death,
maybe also the Nikolai Masha. So anyway, you
can look at all of these and each is very, very
strange. Suffered a stroke. Fell out of a hotel
window, a hospital window, all of these different
things. It's very, very suspicious. And I know
many of you will email me and you will say, David,
what do you mean, suspicious? These people are
obviously being murdered. I understand. Remember,
the whole point here is no one's really supposed
to believe the story that's told. Like you and I,
we see. Oh, it's been reported that they
tripped on a remote in their hotel room
and fell out the window onto six knives. David,
that's not believable. That's the point. Okay,
I can't say all of these are murders, but some
of them are obviously murders. Okay. The point is
that the explanations not be believable because
it's how you communicate. They'll kill you.
That's the entire point. And so it's not
who thinks we're going to believe these
stories. It's that's the whole point. They tell
unbelievable stories. And here is yet another
suspicious one. Put it on the list of suspicious.
Will we ever know which ones are what they are
said to be and which ones are the murders? We
may not. We may not, but it is happening again.